welcome to the morning toast good
morning Millennials we have a very
special episode we're a little all over
the place just to the diva-like
tendencies of one of our guests but
interrupting it's important that
everyone know that Aaron was very much
on time I was early
yes prompt and Sara and I have very
different ideas of what on time means
welcome Sara welcome every time one of
you did we start with that he insisted
he started out yet
oh it's not let me start without you I
insist we start on time oh um that's
Sara and I are unfortunately stuck
together my god I used to running up
your sweater here she's a pro now he's
been here for about ten minutes
so she works here now no so here I mean
you couldn't obviously run the show some
one thing they do what you do it's so
weird Aaron's trying to run the show
Sara and I are obviously stuck together
in ways that maybe you guys are stuck
together and I have learned is invert it
flip it the clip that of instead of
trying to write like this instead of
trying to like micromanage Sarah I'm
back I'm back sir I just don't know what
to do with it
Jackie can relate I can I've been
growing mine out for a while now but a
side part is great it's really good it
looks a little mullet II when I have in
the middle so you know it's not a middle
part situation I lied I wasn't peeing I
was just trying to figure out what you
should get home around with you that's
really good for the part a co extreme
but big mess I always micromanage Sarah
because she's very late she a desert she
just doesn't like follow rules if you're
in a yoga class Oh Sarah and they're
like you know put your leg in the air
you look over and she's doing setups
like she just like it she does not
follow anything it's very frustrating to
someone who likes to follow rules and be
on time so now I've learned that like I
don't sit next to ser on the airplane I
let her be crazy on her own and I we're
not staying at the same place at you nor
you've done that one time
thing but I really liked it I've seen
downtown and she's saying I've town
completely separate we drove here
separately and it's like life is better
do you think I love the Upper East Side
and rare very up recessionary Tribeca I
have my restaurant and Aaron like likes
to hang out with the celebs downtown and
I think you like money and I like
honestly so well put and I just think I
need to point out the importance of you
guys being here cuz we've gotten so many
requests because like sister a military
requested gasps yes really yes but for
one reason that you guys might not know
oh not that much oh yeah in addition to
all the reasons you guys might not know
that your dad is one of the cornerstones
of our show yes why so we started this
show really as a platform to get justice
for David Foster I wiII he wants his
head along with other people who we
think deserve justice Sharpay Evans
Marianna Meredith Blake and guest John
from Beauty and the Beast
Billy and the breeze the breeze serving
justice from sup for someone it's like a
popular phrase now but nobody knows that
we literally started on the show two
years ago about your dad know we got a
lot of trouble trying to get justice for
our dad we got it a lot of stuff so but
we were really the campaigners behind
that whole thing cuz we just thought we
saw it there were different lens you
know and we were introduced here dad
obviously like everyone else I'm gonna
hospice Beverly Hills and that there was
Grammy Award winning word for anything
just great god forbid 95 Grammys you
know we just sought through a different
lens and we love Jolanda but you know we
shot throw to the air and xxx again so
we just got any lenses to see what is
wrong with our culture that it became
Yolanda Foster and her husband David
right what is wrong with the culture no
and when like babyface was out of your
eyes house I was like how did you launch
a no baby she's impressive but so it's
so crazy like you guys being at the
center of like literally pop culture in
so many different ways like there's you
guys have seen I'm so glad a jar that
your family tree oh the Vanity Fair fire
yes and we were right the center of it
and I made a joke I posted I was like
just to be clear I have like four of
these people's phone numbers really like
like legit for
David not play again don't have his
number I thought I can change that yeah
actually I do I you do I don't have his
number I don't have Kylie Jenner's
number that is the number one affiliate
may she change it yeah thing I've ever
met her is the trip but you guys get
free Kylie cosmetics free of Kylie
cosmetics and we have d-end very so the
blood like it's okay Sara like conflict
adverbs like I did yeah I did this whole
post about kite because I love Kylie
makeup you're probably in five Eileen
told Kylie it was jacket I love how it's
so and she replied but not with like her
number or no but she was just like okay
but you guys do you think you pretty
much have like a standing invitation to
Christmas kris Jenner's holiday party
are invited to Rio and it's this year
again yeah and you guys are gonna be
there I don't know that was hard on
Christmas Eve to get away from like
family time to go to a party with you we
have so much family yeah well so Jackie
and I were talking about before how like
you guys have really got ahead of the
joke cuz like your dad has been married
a bunch of times and like two very
prominent people yeah and you guys
really got ahead of the joke in the way
and it's really impressive because I can
now your people you're laughing with
people and people aren't like laughing
at the joke yeah is not an intentional
thing yeah I mean well when we created
barely famous it was a response to the
fact that we always had people networks
saying let's do a reality show with the
foster sisters it's like missing link in
this web of people right and we never
wanted to do a reality show and so
instead I had just come off of writing
on an NBC show and I was like I don't
know what to write next why don't we
write this like satire comedy about you
know our fear was that people in life
would think of us as like idiot bloggers
like children of like dumb actress so
when everyone you know is on or everyone
around you is on a reality show
we've just to finish that thought I just
didn't know it was it it felt like yeah
I wanted you to land the plane with your
fear it it can be viewed a certain way
the best thing to do is take ownership
of that thing and then turn it around
and create the visual and like the
narrative you want like fat Amy from
pitch perfect exactly exactly so we
created a show about two vapid entitled
obnoxious girls but we were in on the
joke and I think that that really like
shifted yes
people want to know when we're coming
coming back with another season are we
listen we would have loved to do barely
sees it barely famous for ten years
right vh1 canceled it oh by that's just
kind of I mean at the end of the day
like I think they loved it and we loved
having the show and it just wasn't the
right fit
it was this like satire comedy on a
network that doesn't really do that it's
definitely more like a material yes it's
like exactly there's a lot of other
networks that it would have done better
on and made more sense on but an E and
E's bread and butter was reality TV so
you were talking about we pitched it to
the ease and Bravo's even though our
dream would have been Comedy Central now
I'm you know I Amazon Netflix wasn't
around the weekday that's obviously the
dream but either we were making fun of
their bread and butter so I think there
was a little bit of hesitation all right
what exactly is this and then when the
show when the first season came out be
like oh we get it right and then they
were like why didn't we get this show we
were like well we pitched it to you
right you didn't guys well we're just a
couple sisters who got our shows
cancelled it's not my idea your show
cancelled - yeah we'll be rebranded it's
a whole thing I'll okay so we got so
many questions for you guys there's no
slug amazing well yeah I'm just gonna
hold on to this [ __ ] time yeah it's
important I just loved by them like in
love oh dear - I will say this we really
appreciate your defending of him because
we have to say we you know we have a
great relationship with our dad who's a
really great guy and I think that what
reality show doesn't show people is what
really goes on of course and so it was
challenging for us when there was a
narrative about him that we knew that
was false yeah and when we made an
effort to you know it's hard to not
defend his becoming a parent when
they're being attacked and falsely
because people who really don't have the
information and so we didn't even plan
on or ever mean to defend him publicly
but we were doing press for our show and
then that's the thing that people would
ask about and I think it just got like
minute oh yeah instinctually you you
know you fight hard for your family but
so what was David's take on the whole
thing our dad is show classy Brad dad is
that we were like yeah you've got to
tell the world that this is actually
what happened and this is it he was like
you guys I would never he's a Grammy is
like yeah he's like I know he doesn't
say that but he's like I'm rich I'm
successful but I have an amazing
life why in god's name do I need to vote
but it was hard it was course
challenging I felt it was challenging
for me yes back then it wasn't better
writer David Foster
Moritz was not even a job well we were
like arguing people in line aren't
acting like can you not do that dosnt
really actually help anything and you
know what does that say about our
society these trolls that's oh that
watch these reality shows thinking so
black it's great other day explain to me
like the lifecycle of a troll and to it
it's so genius I know a troll starts out
just like you meet like a normal person
and first they find something and they
really like it and then they start to
love it then they become obsessed with
it
then whatever it is like does something
that they don't agree with and they feel
this type of like work on their shampoo
feel like they own it so when you do
something that they don't agree with
that like level of love turns into like
equal amounts of hanging and all of a
sudden you find yourself being a troll
and are these like functioning humans
with jobs like yes and with amélie's if
I was ever leaving comments on people's
Instagram like you've got an ugly Jacqui
with text hele do these people have
concerned you know family members I
wouldn't think the same thing it's like
embarrassed I don't think I could ever
get away with doing that people would
say things to me and I naturally would
they clicked on their profile you know
and they'd be like standing there like
holding their baby over yo you have
children yet and you're telling me to
kill myself because my dad was it's like
actually scary
so the I can't help but you know just
think of the Hadid sisters and I would
love to know what your relationship was
like with them do you run into we
honestly we honestly really like the
girls yeah you have but you have to also
remember they were babe they were little
children our parents were together for
ten years so when we met them they were
like 12 younger I think I mean they were
little kids and so if we'd known we
would have invested their careers really
you know maybe scale enormous yawn I
remember say to GT we're gonna be a
model even do that that's like you're so
smart hard it's gonna be a job you know
my girl at every corner
sighs Gigi's very smart yeah
people I don't think know that she's
very smart she's like obsessed with
criminal psychology justice would just
like watch Law & Order all day like I'm
smart do you have no bad blood with that
obviously when people get divorced you
side with your parent you're protective
of your parents the most natural state
in the world there's a big age gap
between us so it's not like we're
hanging on weekends
why are the 21 year olds first of all
the children I know but anyway we don't
look run into them but when we never we
do it's it's all peaceful it's great
well I really just feel like we can
fight like end our show like finally
because we got justice for David Foster
that's what did we change a narrative
between the four of us we're changing
hearts and minds well also something
that my sister Olivia texted me this
morning that I absolutely must talk to
you Sarah that obviously played in your
family of Aaron you played my conic role
in an iconic show 9:02 went out and I
know you hate to talk about it but I'm
not gonna ask you what you think I would
have I don't hate to talk about oh do
you oh I don't I mean where was my Emmy
I mean people anymore I appreciate this
role and I know what it was I feel like
between the dynamic of YouTube like do
you seem a little intimidating just
because of your role like you were so
good at it that would be really cool she
was a really hot thing
by the way Aaron Aaron's I'd never seen
it people air have you ever even seen it
up I was really good you you were really
good and I have I think I've seen it
it's a just staple public about
generation it's just well I wasn't funny
and I don't oh yeah no you were serious
it was just as like impactful I think
it's Gossip Girl like at the time 1,000
right after each other yeah I'm not take
well so what I wanted to say was I
cannot but think of the Megan Markel of
it all and I wanted to know if you ever
saw her around on set or people spoke
about her anyway that was like she was
making mark oh I know she was I was so
getting Ethan a [ __ ] and in the car
in the parking lot that's cool that's
not very royal of her that's whoa
didn't didn't know I've never I'm gonna
beat her
well I thought I interested her first
role no she was on a couple hallmark
movies and them before that an extra she
was a FedEx girl and one of the movies
yeah we know a lot about her good for
you girl you really found only worked
out really worked it out that is not
getting no one's talking about it
- an ogre to coach at know I have this
is news to me I've never that's that's
too but no okay
right cuz I feel like you guys like like
you said like you could have invested to
Gigi's career you could have invested in
becoming friends Megan like so many
opportunities that you guys so we really
miss you
coconut that were yeah we could be doing
a lot better you know what I'm happy
with where we are you could also be
doing a lot worse yeah is your boyfriend
I do yeah and I met him in he's so cute
and so nice and you guys really
complement each other really it's really
embarrassing oh my god is crazy it is
this is embarrassed I think we know it's
embarrassing
what are you doing there it's so cheesy
we're not even like a weird workout
meeting at the gym is cheesy it's so
funny now it's normal to be like we met
in person online now it's normal to say
this but you don't want to tell people
you met at the gym well I just doesn't
feel like the baryon brand for me see I
agree with you and you look a little
disappointed actually I guess so listen
I don't know what happened but we met at
the gym I'll tell you what happened you
slid into DMS
did you he was not paying attention to
you at all or me for that matter
yeah by the way really awesome day he
worked out there too so he could have
really blown up his bot if he was like
hitting on her checking her out he do
think I would smile at him cuz just what
you do at the gym when you're in this
mess is like Equinox okay we were not so
gym tiny private gym very very exclusive
exclusive it's hard it's actually not
that expensive which is why we go there
Erin's a cheating person ever she does
not own a nice pair of shoes you don't
understand first of all these are ragged
moans oh that's be nice okay you
probably got them for free that's true
she does not pay yeah that's true I'm
just talking about this is a retail so
anyways let's go to Mario's Aleutian our
new year's resolution this year's just
to have 2019 be the year free stuff like
way more free stuff like leveraging
whatever it is that we have just to like
not paper soft partnerships you know I'm
his [ __ ] American jeans are genuinely my
favorite new buff G and the best a
really are good and this isn't a Riccio
sweater and I am obsessed with the read
together
and Aaron is a promo code that you'll
read for you yeah I always see people
doing that with promo codes I've never
gone to promo is that a thing like I
don't think you're real influencer until
you okay I've never known to offer me
Sarah also texted me this morning
there's how do I promote being on the
thing
this morning and I was like hmm post a
picture of it and help people to watch
it like she doesn't know anything
shouldn't understand digital anything I
don't but I can repost it when we're
done right yes
okay so I'll do that I'll send you
everything you can't don't worry for you
sir I'm sorry children I don't know make
a difference but they shouldn't really
keep you like up with the time so yeah
but Aaron gives me a very big compliment
she tells me that I don't have mom my
way which is interesting because I'm a
mom but apparently I don't have mom's
vibe that's what kids wait I'm sorry I
just had a thought
Aaron is an apt oh my goodness you're a
famous end you're also famous and I am I
I'm gonna - my famous yes are be your
flow jube like just take a lot of pride
in your aunt duties the most not only
that but she gets jobs off being an aunt
I don't get jobs off being a mom being
like do I like get like jobs to like
spend it with Alan - yeah yeah yeah
that's good stuff z coconut water - I
was her and it's like we would like you
and Valentina to spend the day together
like do it champagne I'm like why
wouldn't you just ask me right to do it
with my daughter Sarah like yo can I
like you know we're kidding how your kid
for a great Zico campaign and she said
yes she got a pair of them but to be
clear I'm not like whoring out my
daughter she recently got asked to
interview Margot Robbie for the cover of
Harper's Bazaar my eight-year-old
daughter which when I've got the
incoming email from the editor of
Harper's Bazaar Zico who are what are we
doing for Harper's Bazaar for my
daughter to interview Margot Robbie but
she said no cuz they're a fly on of her
because of her Instagram she said no he
said you said know where you're going -
no no I'm not man yeah a fellow mom - my
son talked Theo okay wait you don't know
so yes so okay Jackie jack in addition
to serving justice for David Foster
we're also here serving justice for the
importance of ants in a dog and inside
and we're highlighting things ants you
know throughout history throughout
history and Jackie really is like with
spearheading this campaign and it just
dawned on me that you two are and I'm
not just like an aunt I am like a mother
Anne yeah like I am like I think of her
kids as my kids I could take em out from
school they call me when they need like
you know advice I am like the glue yeah
no does the same digit on a Sunday
morning I'll be like yo I can't deal
we're at a copy gonna take her okay both
of them take them
tennis I need a nap yeah yeah so great
and she's usually she's usually yeah I'm
pretty good about it so I was checking I
think of them as my own the importance
of and the importance of em it's a great
role and speaking of family members you
guys are about to welcome a new one
katharine McPhee yeah yeah a segue
you're really good at this they have to
say you guys honestly this isn't me
nailed the interview of a lifetime like
right like this is you guys are just
really the epicenter of everything we
like we could bring up any subject and
find a way to relate the katharine
McPhee of it all they just have loved
watching her career like from seriously
like I watch her American action smash
show talent show to Gary and I waitress
because she was new idea but I heard
rave reviews you can fly to London to
see her and what she she just very good
very good
I'll do that but no tell us about your
relationship you guys seem to like
really get along it's genuine you really
listen our dad has made some interesting
choices in his life so it doesn't matter
how old somebody is yes if they get
along and as a couple they laugh all the
time she's really good to him she makes
the perfect amount of effort with us
like she doesn't get too hard
she doesn't ignore us she helps our dad
like facilitates a good relationship
between us and our dad because she can
relate to her a couple times right you
guys know Meredith like you guys really
I feel like we're the inspiration we
identify with those two little twins I
actually went to home I went to boarding
school in Switzerland by the way didn't
get sent there I beg to go to get away
from right wow that is so [ __ ] funny
well it's really cute to see you guys
like hang on in there
we loved ulanda yes we know I know I'm
just saying we didn't have all bad did
she bring you guys lemons yes of course
of course
she make you go on the Master Cleanse
ever wait I feel like the master we
party and you're really happy for David
and Catherine and I want to say I'm not
gonna lie like ever since they hooked up
like he's answered my texts like but
less frequently wait you have a texting
relationship you guys met at Craig's or
something yes I really knew your dad
like before I knew you guys but I really
use her to you guys because Cade knows
him and goes okay yes of course yes what
is one my best friends and we were
eating dinner and he knew David
oh my god thank god now I get just as
pretty good buster yeah and it really
just likes like snowballs from there but
we have like a loving relationship we
just like met and we connected you know
I'm like a chakra level yes I love that
by the way greed is so good at his job I
know look what he brought look yeah look
we did well in all honesty this is just
yeah you guys had your own thing didn't
you yes I really and that's a real
relationship and I feel like you guys
couldn't speak to that just as much as I
can I'm sure there are people who like
I've never met them and like probably
might never run into them but if I did
I'd be like oh I know you
yeah something that really bothers me on
Instagram is that you get DM requests
from people and sometimes people say
things that are really emotional are
really sweet and you want to respond and
want to engage you want to like by the
way I like to tell somewhere where the
sweater is that I'm wearing that they
want to know I just like to like
communicate that conversation out
floodgates are then anytime I post like
I'm on the morning toast oh my god
excited to watch you and like we're not
friends and it's just the notification
is in a way yes
no the Instagram has to figure that out
like 3ds people need to close out a
conversation
oh no that would be awkward to close out
our conversation I feel differently I
keep my conversations open I like to
engage all the time with my fans I don't
buy that for one sec look at my thing I
keep it I keep it open you can always
tell you Sarah she gets notifications on
her home screen of any human being the
comments or likes on any photo of hers
whether she follows them or not Wow wait
I don't think that's what I get yeah it
is no that's not what I get that's crazy
I don't think on my new phone I get that
you that's crazy you did I get likes
from people I follow I see who follows
me and I see what comments anyone yeah
maybe so I don't get that many comments
here at the morning toast didn't
specifically Club yeah sure I'd love to
pit women against each other and I'm
just sharing it's time for the perfect
I'm just curious if you guys ever get
competitive because people asked us that
we're like no but they don't believe us
do you guys get competitive with like
Instagram followers or like book gigs or
whatever
give me an errand Erin's more
competitive I think everybody I think
wild statements so why it's a wild thing
I don't so that I brought this up
it's a wild day because like
just I don't feel I don't feel
competitive with era yeah I want the
best for Aaron
that's weak that's not what it
competitive me yeah what do you are you
you're getting really have done you're
gonna yeah I hope you okay because Aaron
take this Sarah is known for though
weren't there boy is needing to let
everyone know which ideas were hers okay
so she gets very competitive like when
something happens with something look
we're both throwing out ideas and my
idea it turns into the thing that gets
used for content or something like that
I don't think about it I want it she
always has to remind people that it was
her idea she's very competitive like oh
I invited that person I had that idea I
had this she's very like she needs to
know people don't know and how does that
make you feel Sarah to hear Aaron say
that I think Aaron just really took a
different turn here what does it go of
you know um I think because I'm not
considered like a writer uh Aaron is a
as a professional writer I think that I
write so I probably sometimes get a
little bit not insecure about it may be
insecure where I go wait I wrote that I
wrote it because people don't think of
me right
as a writer people think Aaron is like
coming up with you with all of it but
really coming up with a handful probably
get like that I like the mastermind
behind everything and I'm not oh is
Sarah well no it's just a combination
yeah it's like it says true it's
extremely combination yeah yeah but
that's why I'm like you don't need to
tell me I know you have good ideas all
the time right I think is less with her
and it's more like other people they're
more like the producing partners and
they manager I'm like uh that was my
idea that you know yes yeah and then she
was like but in the big picture very
close like a mile oh yeah but in the big
picture like I think that's why we've
been able to have the partnership last
as long as it has lasted because we
really aren't competitive with each
other like we want the other to do well
and I don't know I can't that would be
horrible if I felt like competitive with
her I don't think I could work with her
well do you guys read what people say
like about your friend like people like
love to
conjecture or whatever the word is about
like yours like people are always at
Claudia must hate Jackie Jackie here
like what we don't like is obviously we
have a banter with each other and we're
we like make fun of each other a lot but
what we don't like is a lot of people
try to connect with us by talking [ __ ]
about the other one and that does not
work because at the end of the day we
have each other's backs on set and
whatever we're saying about each other
and to each other on Instagram has been
pre-approved look at what stage but I
like Sarah we'll say something and be
like wait was that you mean right I
don't even mean and I'm like no I don't
care it's all the things that we know we
can lot we can joke about and so when
someone wants to connect with us by
being like I think you're the better one
or the or the funnier one or Sarah's not
this or Sarah's not that or Erin's not
physical it's like we're not trying to
like bash our sister - with a stranger
you know crazy it's when people write
like Erin so much prettier than you I'm
like who says that like that's weird
yeah it's true it's like yeah it's like
everyone but it's true I think people
think that's the way to end dear but we
don't like that we don't like get [ __ ]
up you know that's [ __ ] up how many
nights a week do you guys like leave the
house I feel like guys are always like
out of events Zarin would you like to go
thirsty Erin's out every night it always
has a plan unless with a boyfriend
oh that's true I do not get it I don't
go anywhere
right unless I'm getting paid or unless
like I don't go on girls dinners I don't
go on girls vacations okay I don't we
didn't just have a gia now and it was
like for the first time ever and it was
so much fun and I would recommend I'm
desperate to do it I have a
three-year-old in an eight year oh yeah
I can you guys I go to bed at like 8:30
I follow those commit early but me being
thirsty I want to go out during the week
to address those comments I would love
to address some comments in that you
know how those make me feel uh when I go
out it's going to dinner with like four
friends or going over to Jamie Nico's
house and cooking or staying in with my
boyfriend and trying to cook so he'll
like marry me great so you know I mean
you're bought that are domesticated in
this relationship yeah because I'm never
gonna say you know you care
I've never wanted to cook for anyone
before oh yes she's like a good cook who
no that's because I've never anyone be
nice to me before probably in a
relationship and so when someone's like
really good to you you want to like be
together and take care of that I've
always been on the defensive end of a
relationship and I'm like [ __ ] you I'm
not gonna take care of you cook for you
you want us on your phone the other day
like
I've never been in a relationship where
I'm not mad at him about anything so I'm
like oh she's only like DMing like chefs
and people that write write a new recipe
thanks okay this is your BMI it's it's
good that means you're growing up yeah I
think so too I look forward to it thank
you for me but you too all right okay
well where can keep people keep up with
the neverending foster sisters where do
you suggest following you
I guess just on our Instagram I don't
Facebook I don't do anything I don't I
mean there's no about a YouTube channel
listen we want to start where to start a
problem at a YouTube channel I was gonna
but now that brushing my teeth brushing
your I was thinking I'm like I wonder
why cuz I was thinking like what are
Sarah and Aaron here to promote her like
nothing I'm like I would never they
don't have a podcast it's really just
been laziness okay and honestly just
trying to figure out the right path
there's a lot of different paths to do a
podcast do you do like do you like live
Torah do you do in a little studio with
like friends do you do it live I mean
this is why our vibe yeah yes is very
relaxed and being live is fun cuz then
like you don't have to think about it
it's like that show's over
he said it said what you said and I
meant it I like that yeah we've have to
edit all that was probably no I think
it's also I don't want to say it's
time-consuming but we've had we have our
hands in so many different things right
now
she wrote a pilot for Fox this last
pilot I said it's about that your life
kind of well well it was it wasn't
really because it was about it was
called daddy issues and it was about a
girl who like yes can't find a good guy
because she has daddy issues and her dad
ends up dating her best friend that was
not based on Katherine even though they
were together at the time and did you
know her that wasn't friends with her
before so I met her through him so that
wasn't really it just like accidentally
kind of happened at the same time yeah
that's cute that'll be good well it
didn't get picked up so oh well what it
does
who is in it we'll see I won Johnson was
you dad yeah that's true
that's would you ever cast Sarah to play
you into something you wrote me probably
not but to play her to play my sister to
play a different character every single
thing I write I write a character for
Sarah that's nice how would you feel
that she's very I need a right for
rectus
well she trusted me in barely famous oh
what's so interesting is I sort of
directed her and daddy issues for the
first time the rules not the rules
reversed but for the first time I was
behind the camera on that pilot and it
was actually a very it was actually a
pretty good dynamic yeah it was but the
point is is that we were so focused on
that and before that barely famous and
then we ended up selling another show to
another network where the creative
director was a bumble we sort of are
wearing a lot of hats and you want to
make sure that when you do a podcast or
whatever that you can fully devote all
your time to make it the best that it
can be so we're just sort of trying to
time management is not the best and in
television at the end of the day is our
bread and butters and it's where the
money's at mm-hmm not on money on
podcast guys yeah you're telling us okay
so make sure you keep up with Sara and
Aaron cos our Instagram it at Sara
Foster at Aaron foster yep easy like the
easiest names ever so we very pretty
like so American and just some jealous
like of what your grade school
experience is like okay so we're going
to take a quick break and we'll be back
with the rest of the show so make sure
to keep up with the foster sisters like
I said on instagram at Sara Foster at
Aaron foster and a 105 good morning
toast on Instagram too like we wouldn't
be upset about it we will be back in
just a minute so stay tuned
you
hey guys sorry we are back I'm like so
out of breath like exhausted that was
honestly like better than I thought it
was gonna be like I knew was gonna be
great but that was even better they're
so funny and like they really like play
into the roles that like they made for
themselves but they are like funny and
introduces and like they have each
other's back it was so enjoyable I hope
you guys enjoyed as much as I did I was
literally just like know that you know
it was actually like easy to interview
them because you didn't even have to ask
a question they just started like saying
what you wanted them to say they really
are pros and it then when they start the
podcast life yeah it'll be good it'll be
easy and they'll secure like the most
premium gas like Nicole Richie life
everywhere honestly yeah makes a lot of
sense yeah but you know podcasting is
hard work
I know people don't understand the life
of a podcaster and like people like who
have a podcast every once a week are
like it's a lot of work and it is but
like we do this [ __ ] five times a day
right once a week is different I can't
imagine having a weekly podcast it
sounds like a dream yeah
just like showing up for work one day
yeah crazy stuff totally like Oakland
Center which I don't know where I think
we're physically off-centered okay I
can't believe it's Monday like now it
feels like a Wednesday well no it was
just a crazy week last week because we
didn't do a show Friday mm-hmm
dude Bijou Margot filled-in Thursday
Margot filled-in Wednesday you did one
with me on Thursday yeah so Tuesday and
Thursday we're the days where like I
wanted to die huh and it was so hard
honestly I haven't had strep since I was
a kid and I don't remember it being
anything like that it was so terrible
I really thought at one point in the
mill that I was like that and take me
the hospital so sad but gotta ask
over/under how much weight did you lose
okay so it lost four pounds I did made
myself today because in the past two
days like it actually I was like loving
not eating cuz I wasn't hungry so I was
like not really I was like living for it
but then I was on so many meds I got
sick again from not eating and being on
augmentin which gave me the worst
diarrhea of all time which is why we
didn't have a show on Friday because it
just would have been a lot of in-and-out
own disaster day I was actually thinking
about it like you might have proved your
pants yeah no 100% but so no that's what
was so obsessed was that I didn't eat
anything and augmentin gives you like
crazy diarrhea but when you have no
nothing to to
it's like it was just terrible stomach
pain with no endgame so I made my
situation worse by not eating so in the
past couple days I'm having to eat a lot
of bread while I take my augmentin so
I'm definitely back up the four pounds
that I lost you know you look great to
me thank you thank you sister daddy back
my weekend was great I feel like we have
so much to talk about obviously you know
the Fast Five and so much TV my weekend
was so good we spent a wonderful day
together on Saturday creating premium
content we did a podcast episode because
we really both like how to pit that we
miss Friday did you guys and so much was
happening so I'm glad that we were able
to do a podcast with the while he licks
my hand the entire time it was a
precious angel man than that of a boy
regular free episode that's available on
Spotify and iTunes then we also recorded
a patreon episode about we did a part
two of all the drama in the Facebook
groups cuz it was never-ending and it
was really funny and that one's
available on our patreon so we were just
working women this weekend and honestly
I don't feel exhausted at all I mean it
clearly
I don't feel well rested at all I feel
exhausted I feel exhausted - yesterday I
slept so good Oh like on Saturday night
to Sunday morning it was a dream it's
like the city was finally quiet for the
first time in so long as it was raining
I go yeah we're like okay we'll stay
home well something interesting is I
made my bed differently I usually make
my bed like a normal person like I
pulled the cover up all the way to the
top and then I put the pillows but I did
something fan film in the back I fold it
no no I folded it half you know how they
do in hotel yes
like fancy-ass and when I got into my
bed after that like my bed was different
and Ben said even said he was like the
bed feels different I'm like that's why
I mean it was really better or worse
much better so actually today is the
first day probably in six years that I
didn't make my bed I just couldn't like
I was so tired and I knew I was gonna
get right back into it after the shows
that's when you know yeah except we
belong at the Sin City just you know
yeah look cuz there's so much you hear
tell for the world doesn't stop turning
I'm sweating in my boot in my breasts
actually my boob sweat has really
decreased since I started I only
exclusively wear my third love bras now
and it's to wear these weird bras from
Amazon that like put squish my boobs
together and boob sweat for someone of
my size is a very real issue that
millions of Americans suffer from every
year and the third men and women oh yes
of course that's just us bed the way
that the third love bra separates my
boobs
it's don't get me wrong I'll never be a
person who doesn't have boob sweat but
I'd say it I've lost about 50% of the
boobs
which if your sufferer you know how
thankful that can be that's great I'm
not even sits up here I'm more of a four
boob sufferer
oh yeah I just really gotten better
since using third love as well like
today I just have and she and I think
everyone in the world knew about their
love before I did right because when we
first started talking about on the chest
everyone was like oh my god finally like
and I was like you got to do about this
and you didn't tell me no I totally
agree but for those of you who are like
us and didn't know about third love it
is just the best way to get a bra there
is a fit finder quiz where you only have
to answer a few simple questions to find
your perfect fit over ten million women
have taken the quiz today including
these two women and are just looking
better off for it there's comfort
quality 100% thick guarantee third love
knows there's a perfect bra for everyone
so right now they're offering our
listeners 15% off your first order go
2/3 love.com slash morning toast now to
find your perfect fitting bra and get
15% off your first purchase
that's third love.com slash morning
toast for 15% off today when it comes to
recommendations like I wouldn't you know
recommend like I wouldn't suggest anyone
listen to my recommendations about like
you know juice cleanses or workouts but
when it comes to boob sweat I'm there's
nobody more wise than me
I completely agree I will so when were
tested birth in the field I just want to
talk about how my shirt it's from shine
shine shine shine she in and I have a
lot of questions about because I said
that I was gonna place an order and the
tow service gave me some good advice and
they were really requesting a follow-up
so I got the package um it did take a
very long time to come from China and I
listened to the testers recommendation
they said do not buy a shirt that
doesn't have reviews because that means
it's fit for a doll and I want to say of
all the things I ordered nothing came
fit for a doll they also told me to size
up because it's so cheap and that was
the one piece of advice I wish I didn't
listen to because everything is huge on
me but honestly not terrible quality I
did need to like steam it but I didn't
question Jebus steamer well I do it's on
the way from Amazon because when I
bought all my stuff from she and it came
so if I can wrinkly that I ordered a
handheld steamer
wow that's really adult of you I seed my
stuff in the shower so that's what um
and it really were it really works
in my old apartment I had like the joy
handheld steamer I don't know how it got
in my apartment but I was so grateful
every time that I did and I got lost in
the move and there's been like three or
four times since I moved where I'm like
damn I need a steamer so I finally went
and bought one and it's not a Stanley
Steamer no it is a Amazon's Choice
steamer interesting I
never know when to trust Amazon's choice
they populate places like sponsored I
don't trust any like even with Google
results like if it's at the top with
like a door choice no no yes Amazon has
the first throw is sponsored and then
they have Amazon but like who are you
Jeff basis you don't know what I need
right and I just don't know if that's
like something you get paid for really
it's like the bestseller because if you
knew what I needed you wouldn't put an
office in New York
exactly well it is esteemed like any job
it is our great great joy to bring you
the fast side stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast also in
addition to the stories there if you
think something you talk about you just
want to put it out there so we don't
forget one better paroles the under pump
girls - dumpling hmm three that might be
it okay okay first story um
continuing piggybacking IC Universe Miss
Universe is what everybody talked about
okay piggybacking off of the drama from
last night wait so with dumpling the
drama from this weekend between Kanye
Drake Kardashian's Ariana Grande we
broke down the whole recap on it on our
podcast episode on Saturday and I'm
honestly so glad because we do not have
the time to know and I'm glad that we
don't like catch up on three days worth
of tweets now we're just like catching
up on right now the sunday of it all
right so if you want our hot take on
that podcast Kylie Jenner is standing up
for her man Travis Scott and wants to
ensure there is no bad blood between him
and Kanye West on Saturday night the 21
year old reality star jumped to the
defense of boyfriend Travis Scott who
also might be her husband but like no
one once they call each other husband
and wife and therefore their boyfriend
it's unclear but it also doesn't matter
no it doesn't matter but it's like she
literally calls him her husband enews
boyfriend
Bryce father of their daughter stormy
webster two days after her
brother-in-law ranted online mostly
about drake and accused scott of
allowing Drizzy to insert quote sneak
disses into his song sicko mode west
also tweeted quote I hit tribe earlier
today now he just hit me more threats on
Saturday morning West tweeted met with
tribe at my crib this morning we express
ourselves it's all love um hell is going
on so in psycho mode Drake and Scott rap
about how they prefer quote checks over
stripes referring to Nike a brand they
both have deals with and adidas which
manufacturers West's
easy sneakers before meeting with Scott
Kanye tweeted quote bet it never be a
checks over stripes line again on a trav
song on Donda and then I guess what
Travis Travis posted a picture of his
check of his check and then Kylie
responded to a fan who commented about
him saying he's not being petty this is
a sweatshirt design the sock is a part
of the design everyone is good moved on
living life for anyone who wasn't aware
of Travis's how to deal with Nike and
still does point is it's all been talked
out it's only positive energy this is
just so weird because I feel like if any
family can really separate like business
money and just like personal lives
it's the Kardashians like they
understand money is money businesses
business and so like Travis having a
deal with Nike like shouldn't be a big
deal like good for him right and the
idea with Puma and getting into in and
the fact that Kanye does adidas like it
shouldn't be a big deal and they're like
the one family who can like separate the
two so this is just weird and very off
brand for them
I agree but they didn't make it super
nasty no and technically like the girls
know how to deal with interpersonal
drama the way the boys you know this
might be a first time offense and I feel
like they actually handled it pretty
well while still keeping the public up
on it because you know Travis is
involved it's just really crazy they all
work in the same field it's like you
know if you like if you and your in-laws
like worked in the same office there's
like a corporate drama ya know like the
corporate equivalent of this is like the
McKenzie file of it all right it's like
if if your brother-in-law like lost the
Mackenzie file or he landed it when I
really wanted that case right and then
and and he botched it and you're like
wow I and you go to get the superior
like imagine the opportunity imagine
amber treating me had I been given the
Mackenzie by alright there's only ever
one Mackenzie problem and you know
here's the thing the thing is is that it
all comes back to Mackenzie file it
really does what true and file I don't
know it's a closed case 8th wonder of
the world
confidential uh anyways I just feel like
all this Twitter drama this weekend is
really so crazy
and this is what will keep Twitter like
a live as a business because for the
most part Twitter is no future like as a
social media professional like I can
firmly say like Twitter is a dying app
it's losing users a social media guru
would you say yes they make no money
like but things like
this will always keep Twitter in the
realm of relevancy so good for them
agreed like snapchat Kylie is keeping
snapchat alive Kanye is keeping Twitter
alive agreed Wow between all and they're
putting so many brands on their back
they are and then Kim Mike keeps interim
interesting buts interesting but like
it's alive its alive and well but she
she keeps it interesting yeah and I
guess you know Kourtney Kourtney keeps
MySpace interesting when we were keeping
Facebook alive with all of our many
groups if you want to hurt all the
chocolate patreon.com slash the mourning
toes what's that Jackie balsa speaking
of more drama that's really [ __ ] wild
and what's the word dirty laundry is
just being strewn about okay JWoww's
estranged husband Roger Matthews breaks
down over restraining order so much
drama happened so much drama
he started it uh it depends who you sign
on social media he's so started in
social media started it in the terms of
airing of the dirty laundry what
actually happened I don't know it's not
my business and we'll never find out the
truth but in terms of start of it in
terms of filming himself in the back of
a cop car in the back of a cop car
that's the Sam hunt song oh my god wait
maybe he was just inspired maybe it's
literally Sam hunt was telling the
future predicting the future about Roger
matheus perhaps I'm gonna try and
explain this story as best as possible
but you know every minute something
changes and someone's editing their
captions and notes are being to be
honest this is the type of story you
really can't follow
oh you happy watching it live no not
even that like we can't recap it for you
but like all I know is that they're
going through a nasty divorce and the
cops were called and then Roger decided
to start airing it on social media
- which Jenni and Snooki both decided
then they had to respond to it's really
unclear like who started it in terms of
the fight and what the hell happened and
I thought they were getting back
together and I thought Roger and I think
like as much as I love Roger and I'm
like really like was here for them
getting back together now that I'm just
watching all this unfold I think he's
kind of crazy and manipulative well
though they were said to be working on
things following their September divorce
announcement it's become clear that all
is not well with Jayde JWoww and her
estranged husband Roger Matthews okay
total side note for thing that we need
to talk about this SML oh yeah yeah yeah
in several Instagram videos recorded
from the back of the police car 43 year
old Matthews opened up about the Millay
that took place at his house earlier
about this great word paid six million
pro
Malay play uh Matthews claimed he called
the police because Jenni JWoww Farley
was hysterically screaming at him and
threatened to call the authorities so he
called them first
authorities you're talking like you're
from Jersey quote I documented with them
that I was concerned she was going to
make up a fake story he said in a video
he then left to her he then left to
record a podcast with his friend and he
didn't come on the morning toast which
you know upsetting which might have
changed things for the better but you
know everyone makes their decisions you
made un now live it did he alleges that
he eventually returned home went to
sleep and was woken up around 2:30 a.m.
by police escorting him out of the house
he shares with his estranged wife this
is a to convene the Jersey Shore star
had a straight obtained a restraining
order against him but no arrests were
made please Joe Matthews to a friend's
house where he done recorded a
teary-eyed videos explaining that he
didn't want to go public with their
issues out of fear of their two children
Melanie and Grayson seeing them later in
life but ultimately he wanted
transparency quote I'm sorry that it has
come to this find one human on planet
Earth who says I didn't fight for my
family you will not find them I will
survive this storm and I am now
dedicated to complete transparency so
that justice may prevail in the end so
he was hizmet theory is to post
everything so that everyone has all the
facts and that like you know he really
is jenny has a bigger platform so he
feels like he needs to think about that
and she has the followers and you know
we don't know what's going on and she's
gets a restraining order against him we
think that he's like I'm crazy I
honestly don't know whose side to take
and it's like so confusing and there's
like too much of information being
thrown at me for me to even like start
to like understand it and I'm not that
interested in that in their like dynamic
to like read all the long captions right
like any caption was so long right so
then jayvo hasn't been responding
directly she put out a statement via her
publicist and then Snookie has been
really going to bat for her which is
basically JWoww's response to roger yeah
which is like I don't know no it's
stupid because you know that like every
caption is approved by Jenny's so like
why don't you just write you want to
look like you're above it but really
you're down there in the trenches in the
comment section fighting off releasing
your nest video of the police there when
Jenny was saying and it was sweet
because she was crying about her husband
to the police but she was like he is a
good dad
like I don't want to keep him from his
kids but like what's annoying is like
there's so much information being thrown
at us but there's no information being
told to us like what the hell started
all this like why are they getting
divorced like what what is the root of
all this what is the root of their
issues right
I feel like it's Jersey Shore family
vacation maybe took them down like cuz
she's like her having to leave right
unlike that ballet time yeah but like
she's working she's provided like she's
making much life that they live a very
nice life
like that they wouldn't die without
Jersey Shore and like she recognizes
that she needs to like pay her dues to
the show I feel like she's very you know
it's it's a lot yeah and he's not a
great it that's something a lot of the
Jersey Shore people struggle with
because they really had to acclimate
into very average normal life with like
this like with this money that doesn't
last forever and now the show coming
back when they've gotten used to being
regular people who like are on the PTA
and send their kids to school but
they're being offered like hundreds of
thousands of dollars but it really
disrupts the family dynamic I feel like
a lot of people are just like in the
Jersey Shore family like are struggling
with that yeah but that's what my
professional take no it's like they're
living average lives while also getting
hundreds of thousands of dollars but
they're living better lives and they
would have if the show never happens
right like just like I don't know but
also it's interesting to see what they
all did with it because like I think
Jenni and so he really were the most
prudent with their success yes like they
still live near where they would have
lived anyway just like in bigger homes
you know nicer cars whereas others spent
at all and didn't pay their tax like
fancy yeah Rolls Royce right Ronald
Fitch Vinny is very prudent yeah you
know I think these still lives at home
sick if there's no he married snitch oh
my god it would be the situation hashtag
a wedding celebration the snitch that
would be their wedding hashtag are your
ears popping no but they're parsed my
ears a popping right now really and not
in a good way but like I feel like I'm
on an airplane and you're gonna step off
into a new land hopefully I mean one can
only dream anyways we're just breezing
through the JWoww and Roger stuff if you
are interested you know go follow for
yourself because they're really like
live streaming their divorce yeah really
airing their shit-stained underwear
right but I thought we just really loved
them and then you have such a sweet
family some whatever I no longer ship
yeah no because this clearly isn't a
healthy relationship but I hope that
they're able to work yeah I've been like
a champion up there it's like I've loved
watching their love grow from just like
when she left that toxic relationship
and in his videos he was referencing
some of her exes and I did not like that
so I'm just not sure I feel myself
turning on Roger when like I was so team
Roger forever because his Instagram so
funny but I don't know Instagram is such
a lie and like and this is this is a
perfect example but you really don't
know what the hell is going on behind
closed doors because like in serum would
say they had the perfect life no but you
really don't know what's going on behind
closed doors Instagram is alive but
they've always been so honest with their
Instagram and that like but I thought
that's what made them retain about
that's what we you know like he would
post stories like jetties and on the
[ __ ] out of me yes kids are crazy life
is boy it was too real you know it yeah
it was like a cry for help
yeah that's not that's not good speaking
of a cry for help
this story is really sad Colin Kroll the
co-founder of vine and the founder of HQ
trivia was found dead in New York Colin
coral chief executive of popular quiz
app HQ trivia was found dead Sunday
morning in his apartment in New York
City according to law enforcement police
found his body while conducting a
welfare check at the request of a
concerned woman he was 34 that's so
shady what the hell is a welfare request
and who is a concerned woman um a
welfare check is when you don't hear
from someone for a while you call the
police or like their landlord and they
will get into the apartment and check
out the cause of Carl's death has yet to
be confirmed by a medical examiner
police said but several reports
including in the New York Times have
said Crowell died of an overdose and
that cocaine and heroin were found near
his body [ __ ]
that's really sad that's really sad
and when I read the article I was trying
to find like what he died from minutes
and before they knew it was like a
confirmed overdose he said there was
drug paraphernalia in his apartment and
like that word paraphernalia is weird
why don't ya know like I don't know why
I like when I think of paraphernalia I
think of like titty tassels hey that's
the titty pad of paraphernalia no but so
yeah but it's like drug paraphernalia so
I'm like there were two tassels next to
the bomb uh perhaps I mean sure and like
drug paraphernalia is like so big like
okay like was it a joint a bomb or was
it like I neither want a spoon when I
think of drug paraphernalia I think
a big bong right but like that's not
what causes it overdose
no this story is really sad so young and
successful HQ trivia tweeted we learned
today of the passing of our friend and
founder Colin Crowell and it's with deep
sadness that we say goodbye our thoughts
go out to his family friends and loved
ones during this incredibly difficult
time does HQ still go on write them I
believe H cube does go on because I saw
a story about like that Scott Rudovsky
in the opening did like a festive eulogy
firmly does any Jenny guy still play HQ
because they talk about a fall from
grace talk about a blast from the past
yeah like that was the hottest thing
ever and I when it was happening I was
like I love this game so much like I
hope it never ends like that and a day
later like I forgot about it right like
it's never gonna end I'm like I could
tell you right now that it's gonna end I
could tell you who's gonna end when
Skyler gasps he came on our show and was
so unbelievably rude and like the only
thing people wanted to know was like
where does the $10,000 come from and he
looked wouldn't tell us and he was a I
think he was like made seob
weird for wanting to know yeah like
literally the most requested question
the only thing you're like no offense
like he's not like HQ is like but him
what could you ask him besides a
questions about HQ he's not like doesn't
this porno the size question is like how
did you get this job how did you get
here
right I took the subway right right that
was his answer when I asked him how'd
you get to where you are and as a
comedian myself I just have to say that
is probably the worst type of humor like
not funny dad jokes that are like a
little off like rude you know
yeah I mean he was like wow you guys are
really nervous to be talking to me were
like we are please I spoke to many tell
emailing kept this morning I'm fine
please I've got to say Mehdi telling him
she was on with your life no beard we
have to talk about it okay we're
breezing through the stories it's the
next story is just some speaking of
Megan Markham
uh-huh Prince Harry will snub
traditional royal family boxing day
shoot to avoid upsetting animal lover
Megan Oh Prince Harry 34 has taken part
in the family event for more than 20
years but Megan strongly opposes blood
sports and refuses to wear any fur
Megan's aversion to hunting is believed
to have first caused issues last year
insiders say that Harry has changed
hugely since meeting his American wife
what's the event so Prince Harry must
head on the traditional Boxing Day
pheasant shoot with his brother Prince
William at
to avoid upsetting his animal loving
wife so it's like a pheasant shoot
because they do every year and like if
you watch the [ __ ] shoot
pheasants are like Birds it's hunting oh
that's sad
honestly this is one thing Megan Marco
being a diva I can get behind but like
hunting is like really important to the
Queen no totally doesn't with his
brother every year and this just
solidifies that there's tensions brewing
no no and it's don't get me wrong it's
very sad that a tradition is is ending
but some traditions you know have to end
and this is one that I don't I won't
miss and this is where like Megan Margo
coming in as like a biracial divorcee
like being all progressive this is one
thing she's doing I'm like yes [ __ ] you
get those save those birds save those
pheasants save those pheasants and I
guess you have to wear fur when you go
so let's have a look yeah I'm looking at
this picture of them here it doesn't
look like they're anchor but she one
doesn't wear fur and two is anti-hunting
no I'm here like this is a diva like
tendency I'm behind Thank You Megan for
bringing some some justice for the
pheasants I don't know I mean the
justice today has been just like over
seven ting advocate by any means but
like this is a standing tradition um and
it just seems like just so crazy to be
on upended bus because Megan doesn't
like it but it's like the world changes
so much and like hunting back wing that
you needed to hunt to live to wear those
furs to to not die in the cold winters
and to feed off their energy every piece
of the Buffalo like to me that's no
question like we gotta hunt but now it's
like we can make a jacket out of
anything
McDonald's is churning out food like we
don't need to kill anime you don't need
to hunt for sport for sport like that's
stupid I agree
like and to like you know I'm Megan good
for you no I agree but that is being
looped into like her and Kate and like
this is different
I sir have a nice thanks no but I see
how admire I think it's both yeah I
don't think it's being looped into I
think it like it is she's definitely
like leaning on this like no I don't
hunt so I can't hang out with
communicate that day right but I great
hunting for sport it's very it's so
unnecessary
I think of the past it's just like how
you back in the day you have to go look
at an elephant in an arena because like
we do have no Geographic because you
needed entertainment but like now you
can go watch out on your TV and like
leave the element fins right and this is
a perfect segue like into the straw it's
like it's like we still need then like
we live in a world where we need straws
we don't need
classic but we need two straws you know
what I'm saying so I don't think we're
at the point in the world yet where we
have a sustainable alternative and I
don't think we need to be getting rid of
them it's just some job the way that I
feel about straws like even if we don't
need them and even if they're terrible
it's just like I am so attached to them
it's the way that like the Queen feels
about hunting yeah like we don't need it
it's not good for the environment but I
do know maybe but but at least I mean I
guess you're right animals are suffering
it's the same thing mm-hmm
Wow really puts things in perspective
yeah the hunting of it all the broil of
it all honestly I can't think about
anything these days until the Telus
craft movie comes out like it's
literally like on my list of things
really cuz like first of all it's such a
good day because we're gonna be in glam
that day and there's actually like a lot
of downtime when you're in a bridal
party cuz like it's not about you but
you have to be there early and stuff for
pictures so we're gonna have a lot of
downtime just like be watching it it's
crazy how like you on a wedding like
your wedding starts like seven o'clock
but you have to wake up at 8 a.m.
Oh torture it takes me 30 minutes to get
ready but like even for a black-tie fair
yeah it will take me the same amount of
time to get ready for the toast the
airport as if actually these days I
don't wanna make up to the airport
because I just don't want you guys to
think I endorsed any of any of the
things that you do the conditions but
like I wear the same man makeup any time
I go Tommy go for the most part which is
also crazy I'm really excited about it
I'm hoping that children some of the
secret stage like secret reputation room
no no like the does why can I think of
what she said secret song what surprise
song so every so every every I'm like
having a stroke give a good talk every
show she did a surprise song from
different albums like she didn't read
you know losing it was blue like I'd
never known miss a new mr. krei alone
and I hope she does some songs from the
red album on state of grace state of
grace like just on what we get to see
you know did we talk about Maggie Rogers
Tim McGraw yet
I don't know but speaking of red Jack
and I have a really exciting partnership
turnout oh wow that's and a great segue
it's a good it's a good segue and it's
also for a good cause so I'm like I'm
really jazzed about this right so we
partnered with the nonprofit red that
makes it easy and fun for you to join
the fight against AIDS
it's Bono's organization so it's cool
it's very cool and they're doing the
coolest thing that I'm so excited to
tell you guys about because they took
you're gonna love this and I also need
to throw in for it right now red is
running their annual shop it's on
campaign a holiday shopping extravaganza
offering red products and celebrity
experiences that fight AIDS with every
purchase for just a ten dollar donation
to read on Crowdrise comm slash red you
can enter to win a number of
once-in-a-lifetime celebrity experiences
including so you $10 and you get to
enter enter for all of these things
they're gonna die because this is some
of these are your dream one Bono and
Lady gaga write a song about you oh my
god what would they say she has the most
amazing buzz she should sing the song
honestly if you win you should have them
write it about the oh yeah because
precious gems I'm just gonna have to be
called Claudia to hang out with Drake
and take selfies and even bag over
apparel and pointing out about the beef
of course we go on a double date with
army hammer and it's an Elizabeth
chambers hammer oh my god all for $10
yes
Thor let Penelope Cruz teach you to
curse like a sailor in Spanish Oh some
wet after then separate them out there
five join Snoop Dogg for a culinary
experience in the kitchen you probably
ought to smoke weed with him too
Oh first six experience the thrill of
performing live with Brad Paisley you
get to go to one of his shows and then
come out for a song I said that you may
be nice dawg
that Bono and Lady gaga wrote about you
per hat and I drew in a bob that's like
my dream I'd be out here and I would do
the duet he has with Demi Lovato without
a fight
oh okay and I would like to learn all
the female parts wow that's so good you
need to put in for that one female part
sounds like I'm talking have a job
there's so many other ones and another
one that I'm obsessed with is go under
pants shopping with Sacha Baron Cohen
perfect perfect oh these are all so in
tune that's so fun and so you only spend
$10 and you get to do a chance to win
all that and the ten dollars goes to
fighting AIDS which is like the greatest
thing ever
and Jackie Miss explaining to me because
I was like how does this company this
nonprofit of so much money to do all
this stuff she was like it's a hundred
percent of the profits go to fighting
AIDS it's not a for-profit company right
so it's really a great organization you
can enter to win or start a fundraiser
at Crowdrise comm flash red you can even
give you can even gift an entry to a
friend way better than a lotto ticket
and better and prizes anyway Crowdrise
calm
I know where I'm going after the show
well that's so exciting I'm gonna do it
cuz then I get to like do ten dollars
for charity then also like maybe have a
chance to be me Lady Gaga mm-hm
very exciting stuff what was your song
about you be called Claudia oh no a star
is born
shallow I'd have a call shallow always
remember us to say fifth and final story
oh hey Wow
it's a little bit of nobody would you
call this sort of news what is he what
is that NBC categorize it as what kind
of news is it I don't know but it's
interesting news okay he's a goodness
now if you live in Utah you like to
drink
Utah set to drop blood alcohol limit to
point zero five for a DUI we know it now
you know it's not good news if you live
in Utah I like to drink and drive
no but which is now the strictest in the
country because everywhere I go down to
point zero five every realm a point zero
eight it should be [ __ ] point zero
one I'm nuts like if been like has one
sip I'm like words were taking AB like I
don't think that's cool at all in there
like losers in high school who think
it's like cool to like haven't be a pro
like drive through the suburbs like
you're a [ __ ] loser and I hate people
who drink a drive like I hate you even
one drink and drive yeah sit look right
so that that's like a thing it's like
you can have a wine and like no it
shouldn't the legal age i'm not age the
point or whatever should be point oh one
so no drinks at all no even if you're
going to just dinner you have a beer
with your dinner and then you drive home
now
no okay Utah will impose the country
strictest limit for alcohol consumption
later this month just in time for New
Year's Eve
the law which was passed in March 2017
by governor gary Herbert will define
driving under the influence as having
quote blood or breath alcohol
concentration of point zero five grams
or greater which is lower than the
nationwide standard of point zero eight
it also states that a person with blood
alcohol concentration level of point
zero five or higher who quote operates a
motor vehicle in a negligent manner
causing the death of another will have
committed an automobile homicide a
felony so thank God Krystal's doesn't
live in Utah well I mean he's already
get one into the slammer the law will
take effect on December 30th I mean it's
a great state to implement it in because
they already probably like the right
amount of drinkers and they regulate the
alcohol so much because it's a
government
doors but also if you think about it
it's a great state to start it in
because there are a lot of parts in you
tell like when though it's really windy
roads and it snows a lot of the year
like it's dangerous driving conditions
sober so I'm here for it I'm such a
weenie when it comes to stuff like this
like I do not think it's cool to drink
and drive I don't think it's [ __ ]
cool to Instagram story and drive and
there's so many influencers to do it
like they're literally on the road with
their car and like I love this I love
Brett man rocks so much I think he's so
funny but like when he does on his card
he's fully driving and they know he uses
a tripod like it's just so dangerous and
I just don't like it
I agree sorry not sorry
um and I'm not proud running and driving
by any means but this is really as it
sounds like you are this is really
shaped as well as should this is like
the one like if you can avoid like there
are so many people who have like lost
loved ones and drink drunk driving which
is the most easily avoidable way to die
like it's so annoying and it's cuz
you're a dumb idiot who likes thinks
it's cool to like have beers and drive I
[ __ ] hate people like that and I
think this is a great law and good for
Gary Arabelle for doing this drug and I
have an inside joke we went to there was
a in restaurant Israel called Herbert
Samuel who was like a historic character
politician or whatever and the
restaurant was called herbart Samuel and
like everyone is real books like this
and I was just being annoying and I was
like f Bell Samuel and that's really how
they all say it they're like welcome to
elbow
Samuel so that I can know or like let me
take a cab and it's also there's a
street boys you're like famous the sky
and you are getting into kaksi and you
have to want to go to the street I'm
going to share my house bells
Sam Wallace yeah yeah and I just can't
see the name Herbert
without thinking about it and honestly
that name is very close to our family it
was our grandpa's middle name no our
dad's middle name yeah yeah it was yeah
it was daddy's little a man like I just
did little did I know before he passed I
was like I could have known that my my
father was Michael a belt
honestly I just love talking that way
yes belt well quickly talking about
Israel I need to talk about this
universe Israel was totally shafted
honestly like it was like apparently
Israel it's just saying the word Israel
is controversial like they had to intro
video where all the girls like would
walk up and they'd be like Angry Allah
you know like
yeah Israel literally she can't even
walk she was like so fat they went so
fast over her name cuz I guess they just
didn't want to be controversial which is
just so stupid
Jackie it was chilling he didn't get one
second I couldn't even see her face it's
not I was like okay and I was waiting
cuz it was alphabetical like I it was
like India there were so many AI ends
I'm like where's this Ralph oh I missed
it you blinked you could have missed her
I have to say I don't know when in the
year was that um lovey oh my I was it
last year Nate might have been two years
ago actually but honestly I just have to
give him so much kudos like first of all
he came back and there were so many
jokes about other people made it he made
it the Internet he is ahead of the joke
he was being so funny like he some girl
was like you have any advice and he was
like read the envelopes carefully
like he was being really funny and I
just felt like it was so embarrassing
for him it was like a national like
international global tragedy and he got
out really ahead of the joke and I was
like really impressing he was being so
funny and like it was really not
scripted like I he was emanating from a
teleprompter but he was improving a lot
and I looked really impressed said
you're on this global stage and I just
thought he did a really good job and I
wanted to give him kudos how was the
show oh you still love that [ __ ] well it
came it was two hours and after the
first hour of end of her parole started
so I didn't watch a second hour it was
produced really well they had Ashley
Graham Carson Wentz and like this world
renowned pageant queen who weighed one
pound like she was I thought she was
going to blow away like every time
someone spoke her I thought their breath
work it's gonna blow this girl away she
was so frail and they were like a cute
panel Ashley that was really funny and
like she has a good personality and I
liked they didn't they chose really well
I'm which was good it's like every time
they have like just some girl from like
the chew and like this she's so
uninteresting right they had a good
panel and Steve Harvey was good um it
was it was okay there's so many women
it's like overwhelming you can't even
get to know any of them so they cut down
from 94 to top 20 which I once you get
the top 20 then you become like much
more like attached to the women and so
it was five from each leg region so they
have like Asia and Africa and then five
wild card and obviously America got the
wild card and like because it's like an
American produced show and the shows in
English which is so unfair like I don't
know what the the global language is
like what's the most spoken language but
I don't think it's English and it was so
unfair like the girls from Australia
just had stuck
leg up over like a girl from Cambodia
like who just had like she learned like
she memorized the English phonetically
do you know a name yeah it was like so
unfair and nobody used a translator I
thought that was so weird and
interesting and it seemed really like
unfair yeah that seemed like more work
for some people I work for other people
and like so much of the the show was put
puts emphasis on the interview and just
like how you there's they they gave them
a lot of talking opportunities I'm like
that's so unfair yeah just a thought
interesting so who won Philippines which
is so funny because that is also the
girl last year who won with lost yeah
she she won but then Colombia gosh she
was the lala land yes but no Philippines
won and she was really cute and it was
in Thailand and like any Asian country
like that made sure the top-20 got like
the loudest cheers like Philippines got
such a cheers Thailand obviously got
loud cheers but like during the the walk
there was like Malaysia like everyone
they got such it was like almost unfair
were there any good questions no and
honestly I think they put the people's
stuff in the teleprompter because like
some of the girls were too well-bred you
know interesting interesting but I was
busy watching dumpling very similar
dumpling dumpling very similar yeah
pageant movie pageant notoriety I would
love to hear your thoughts make some
Netflix movie it's based off a book
Dolly Parton produced it but I was
surprised she wasn't in it like at the
end just like a little something I was
glad she wasn't in because it was like
all about her without having her so it
was cool um I really overall enjoyed it
um now that I have to talk about it I
must I sect it and rip it apart um first
of all like the character what was the
girl's ability she was so cute and so
funny and like oh she had a bad [ __ ]
attitude she had a bad attitude she was
accusing everyone of like of judging her
when she was the most judgmental oh ha
and she like from the jump accuse her
mama being ashamed of her when like her
mom was never ashamed that's what I was
watching with Margaret I was literally
yelling at the TV and I didn't like that
the movie never addressed the fact that
like yes Jennifer Aniston was busy but
she would never and when the woman was
like oh this must be your daughter and
it was her friend she was never like
never ashamed
she'd never and I never for one second I
got rubbed the way that like Jennifer
added said like wished her daughter was
skinnier or wish her daughter was in
badness she just like she was busy and
she was like a little self-involved the
mom
that was Eden that's the only thing I
would accuse her of and they never
addressed the fact that the mom did
nothing wrong
no the mom did nothing wrong other than
be busy and try to provide for her but
it's not like she ever like critiqued
what she ate or writers do this and the
only time that you could say that she
was was when Willa Dean entered the
pageant but the mom was just worried she
was gonna make a mockery of it because
she hated the way she was planning on
making a mockery right and like that's
her life's work I couldn't have even
been to have your daughter come in and
like embarrass you yeah I would be
worried about but not embarrass you by
the way she looks but like embarrass you
by like literally purposefully trying to
take it down from the inside which is
what she was trying to do so Jennifer
Aniston wasn't wrong and being skeptical
right and I just want to say the MVP of
the film Mills Millicent and I've heard
there's a second book that's all about
Millicent and her new life is like
checkered Arab and they're thinking
about making a second movie just about
Millicent like I gotta blow her she was
the protagonist I needed and I knew I
knew they were gonna like make her win
like I because she had such like a good
attitude and I loved her and like she
she was really like what the movie was
about like really not caring and like
not seeing any difference in yourself or
anyone else based on size or any other
reason like I loved her no she was the
definition of just like self-love yes
and just true confidence right I loved
her and it wasn't until she was doing
the pageant and she was being so goddamn
cute and then I was like this [ __ ]
might win yeah and that she has what it
takes she's she studied all the moves
like she worked just as hard as anyone
else and he's actually harder and I was
so glad she was second runner-up and I'm
actually really happy that Doug Cameron
won one because I love her too because
she was so nice and all of the girls
except for that one girl who worked with
the friend who like was weird she wasn't
not nice she was just thirsty
she yeah she wasn't that nice she was
just like Madison overly nice using the
rest of the girls including Doug Cameron
were so nice and enough Cameron worked
hard she yeah this is what she wanted
like her arms like in real like
realistically like Geoff Cameron is the
type of girl who wins a beauty pageant
in the south like that is just what
happens so I'm glad it wasn't
unrealistic but they Millicent coming in
second like she should have no and Geoff
Cameron worked her whole life too for
this pageant and these girls decided a
week ago they wanted to be part of it
and you know what good they worked hard
for a week right and I was so happy with
the final result except I think that the
end should have got in third place not
the got third place the thirsty girl
oh did you yeah but the friend was
really good yeah yeah no I thought the
friend might win at one point and the
friend was like meeting justice she put
up with so much from bad attitude
orleans mom like she never ever judge
will Deanne and well Dean kicked her to
the curb and joined this new band of
misfits but what about your other misfit
I know and she like went through this
cuz she's not like bigger that much
different like she doesn't get to be
included in revolution right and like
just because she liked she was starting
to like like the dancing and hanging out
with nice cool girls with similar
interests like Willa Dean couldn't
handle it and they were nice right so
that's the thing it's like there was no
bully right and it's such a good movie
actually like and it was so well done I
feel like they really captured the
small-town oh my god in the boy with a
lollipop oh my god I loved him he was
really cute but again she was me didn't
you yeah she deserved it that boy like
Nelson she would have she wouldn't
question it she'd be like yes yeah I
good for you like no she was being mean
to everyone and I'm glad she like came
to her senses and right right at all of
her wrongs and when she performed at the
end like I was just like living the drag
queens like really made the show oh yeah
like literally and figuratively like I
just loved and and I loved how
Millicent's mom like didn't become like
didn't really drag her out like she came
around do you know it was also but she
didn't have to come around for anything
she was so proud of her daughter I know
like it was such a good movie and like
and her daughter didn't have to change
it all she just needed to like try yeah
um and but what people are saying in the
book Jennifer Aniston's character like
is the worst okay okay but in the movie
did it make sense like and I'm not gonna
base it off of what someone writes in
the comments this claim happened in the
book I didn't know that but they would I
just thought her response to her mom was
really over Joe Radek
yeah I'm warranted agreed and as an
Anthony chess I just I love the aunt
appreciation of course you do um aunt
Lucy was just a warrior and she was a
great guy I like knew she was gonna drop
dead just like by the way they were
narrating it and but they never told us
what she died from no yeah that's what I
was [ __ ] annoying I was reading tweets
or no the comments on the morning toast
post of Aunt Lucy what did she die from
her life to her health choices that's
what the mom said no the mom was just
like maybe she'd still be here like if
she was probably just like in poor
health and like died like a normal way
but and and I guess Jennifer Aniston's
gripe was like maybe if she had not been
overweight like it would
wouldn't have contributed to her health
issues which is like a legitimate claim
I guess I guess but anyways the Antonis
of it all right and then it really
highlights the importance of ants in the
child's life right what you've been just
basically doing but as an ant I just
want to say like on behalf of moms like
as an ant like it's really easy to be an
app because you get all of the perks and
much less of their responsibilities but
like the mom have to put food on the
table like you know yeah it must be nice
for the auntie drive around town and
listen to dolly Mario but the aunt did
have a job I don't know what it was but
they had dual income and that's why she
was like I have to start doing Taylor
right operations but I'm just saying
yeah must be nice like I'm sure the mom
wants to drive around and listen to
dolly - of course who doesn't want to
think that's right like I obviously love
dolly but I didn't know like her catalog
yeah and I know her catalog work in 95
so I'm like now like into dolly and I
know I watched a movie with Margo and I
know she like went home and like Spotify
dolly um also it gave me very much
Ciara bird just as elusive rides because
it was like it was what Sara Burgess
tried to do what that movie did right
and also we said the same thing is like
this girl on this protagonist it's like
you want to she thinks the whole world
is against certain really like everyone
is being very kind to her and she thinks
she doesn't deserve loves because of her
way that said no but she don't deserve
love cuz it be mean to everyone right
especially your mom she was so mean to
her my writer Burgess exactly so I just
it was giving me like that sort of vibe
but I guess that's the kind of like
Nessa feel good and but it's a good
message and like I'm loving that movies
are just moving this way and I'm just
like so here there's so many things
about 2018 that I can't [ __ ] stands
right I can't stand like being a part of
this like canceled culture where
everyone's like I've said about
everything but like in in there its own
weird way it's moved us into this like
generation of movies we're like the
starring like the top movies on Netflix
this year like didn't start people who
you think are just like skinny blonde
girls right it was just like a diverse
rolodex of interesting people and thank
you gives me hope
right as a diverse interesting person
but then I also still like how they
didn't make like the skinny guys and
girls out to be [ __ ] right and I
think that's that's so easy to do like
oh yes the the overweight complicated
girl is is the kind one and everyone
else is just an [ __ ] yeah but it was
a more nuanced portrayal right of
pageant girls mhm and
just and like that they're not just
[ __ ] who care about themselves who
care about their skincare routine right
like they're all so nice to each
there's a nice sisterhood married I just
go home and they do their key ology
right geology should have sponsored the
patent shut up shoulda woulda coulda
missed opportunity I'll talk to them
when I talk to them later but I'm
oncology I use the cleanser moisturizer
and there's one more toner toner yeah I
mean I've never used to honor in my life
and I love that I don't need to know
what it does it just says toner and I
just put it on my face right you just
send pictures of your face yeah they
tell you that like the awkward part so
you have to like when you okay so cure
ology is it's a new skincare company and
they make you send pictures of your face
and like talk about what type of skin
you have and like I felt so awkward
taking those pictures
yeah man it's cuz you can't wear makeup
they need to see like a full baby to eat
all of your pores yeah
and they did i sat in the natural light
but now you're leavin their reward ya
know it's easy because it just says do
this do that
I don't understand skincare I don't
assume the medicine behind it and thanks
to cure ology I don't need to tote and
neither do you go to college e.com slash
toast to get your first month free plus
a free gift just paid 49 495 for
shipping oh damn that's not a lot I was
like fortunate for Dalton for shipping
that's a lot no $4.95 that's cure ology
comm / toast for your first month plus a
free gift
cure ality cure ology dot-com / toast i
use it it's really it's actually really
helpful and if someone who's always
trying like shitty like drugstore
products it's nice to like have
something affordable that just shows up
on my house right and it's not shitty
and I never have to leave the dream the
dream okay back to the list of things
you must discuss Bannerman rules Jack
and I were talking about before the show
how it's so great on Vanderpump rules
it's like and it's it's ease in mind it
should be like you know like OC vibes
like just not good it's so premium like
it's still dramatic and things have
shifted and there's things I need to
take care of like getting rid of Lisa
Vanderpump but and it's good it's good
last night's episode was good what
bothered me is that the promo for the
episode was Lisa get was Katie Katie
Lisa ultimatum and then that happens at
the end of the episode and it's a to be
continued so literally none of our
questions were answered right um James
crying next week um he always cries when
he gets but not take away his see next
Tuesday's like I'm crying but it's
annoying cuz like he should be fired and
he's making an unsafe environment for
women but in real life like I see on
Twitter he's hosting - see you next
Tuesday next week so like Lisa's thirsty
for that money - right
and I think
Lisa would never run a minute but like
see you next is really successful I
agree it's like a great way to bring
people into Sur and for the fans of the
show to feel like they are get to be a
part of it and to know that if they go
to sur that night there's gonna be
confirmed abandon from pearls like when
we go like for dinner for like a joke at
Sur like go to we never know if that
people are gonna be there right it's
like an annoying but we're in town on a
Tuesday I would totally go I'm Tuesday
because you know confirmed this event at
least James and marquel are gonna be
there
right maybe I don't know if I would go
but rational but right and it's hard to
say that my thing is her favorite has no
mercy but like see you next Tuesday's is
a good idea
yeah and it's a success and no one else
was doing that before James like no one
else had that entrepreneurial like
brunch with Billy I don't think it's
popping right I can't wait for when
Billy and I start to fight you know I
can't wait for Billy like Billy is upset
she gets a no camera time in like I am
too because I just want her to be the
first monster that she is cuz like she
and Sheena have been complaining on
Twitter that there's like they're not
included in the show at all and like
they're not and Sheena is really not in
the show it was crazy
yeah well I think that what I'm diving
from watching the season without them
breaking down the fourth wall too much
just like I think when they're not
feeling like Sheena is really not in
town like she went to Vegas to do her
thing I think she came back started
filming and she's a nice girl like
Ariana Stassi Katie and Kristen they are
best friends and their boyfriends are
best friends and I think they're
together all the time I like was I was
freaking out last night like when ariana
is just like so in with like Stassi
Katie and Kristen for so long she was so
against it and she was so mad at scheana
for like wanting to be a part of it but
she didn't wanted to be a part of it in
a way where like they didn't treat her
equally and like she loved it you know
where's like ariana is coming us like
just an equal friend and they like
Ariana and they finally got to a place
where they're all friends with Ariana
but I just like can't believe that like
she's like well if I'm gonna hang out
with girls who don't hang out you know
like that's not my problem
but I think that there's also like
brewing tensions between Ariana and
scheana because like scheana isn't
around that much and like no when it's a
Wednesday night and they're not filming
like she is hanging out at Tom and
Katie's apartment right like these are
her actual friends but there's
definitely tension brink is like for so
long ariana gave scheana so much [ __ ]
for wanting to be friends with this
girls and like now she's just found to
them because like it's easy and seamless
and like they really they have a good
friendship it should be however it
really bothered me that like Stassi had
laughs like eat so much [ __ ] what
Ariana's friend and it's like first of
all sassy no I thought the REO weird too
it's weird and it's just like not the
staff thing I know and love no and it's
almost like she Ariana made Stassi like
mates like narrated it as if Stassi was
this like mean-girl bully so in order
for Stassi to debug that she had to eat
[ __ ] it can't be the mean girl which is
a WeHo if I'm like begging Ariana to be
friend just being constantly like
offended it's almost like a smart
strategy of obstacles portrayed for a
while as like Mean Girl HBIC like
whatever she says goes and Ariana like
thought she was above it and Stassi let
her think she was above it just so that
they could get to this place
I understand um as a Stassi scan I I
don't like to see it let me know where
and it's like I love who Stassi is now I
love to she was in season when I was
always on her side when Jax got that
girl pregnant I never faltered for a
second raver and it's like even if he
hadn't gotten that girl pregnant just
the fact that they're rumors about him
getting a girl pregnant it's like why
are you in that position together
there's smoke sometimes but I'm not
gonna go back to season one but like
season one sassy like it was justified
and I don't she had to eat so much [ __ ]
and I understand like she that's like
she wanted to because she loves these
girls and like she just wanted to like
be back in their good graces but like I
I think I don't think that she needs to
do that especially not anymore no not
anymore she did when Jewish go to New
York and thought she was better than
everyone and because the show blew up
and she became the most successful and
had those innocent followers and had a
podcast and had a boyfriend in New York
and thought she didn't need the show she
needed to eat [ __ ] to come back and
start over at super the [ __ ] was the
only time within this group of friends
it's now been like three or four years
since that and like I want Queen Stassi
like like HBIC back I know it's still in
her I know of course it's like you could
see it sometimes it like it was out of
her pores no and I love it and it's so
that's like we get the best content um
when Katie went to do her ultimate and
I'm by the way like I don't know why I
can't everyone talks about Katie's
weight like this is like some big think
she looks so fine and so normal she is
the most average body ever but when she
went to go talk to Lisa she was sitting
and like some of the best lighting I
think I've ever seen anyone on reality
TV look and she looked so pretty
mm-hmm and like I always think she was
pretty but like she looked like she had
this heavenly glow about her and I was
like what is this light I'm sure Lisa
was upset you
sit on that side no and I'm sure Lisa
chose her seat for of course she made
the wrong choice but then we need to
talk about the telly Mellencamp of it
all it's her brother gonna become like a
cast member I didn't know I feel like
that's something we would have read
write on a spoiler and assuming he's
like the same actually Teddy's only 30
she's Jax's II yeah Jax is still a Texas
40 right she's Shep's age so this is her
younger brother
he's probably 32 and she like oh she
they're all older than you would think
cuz they they party and go out like
they're 20 21 year olds in LA but no
they're all like older they're all in
their 30s and I think that's like such a
good it's so funny cuz like Beverly
Hills and banner from pearls is like
always crossing over and like it really
organic ways but like Teddy Mellencamp's
brother is dad is John Mellencamp he
need not be a busser you know not a
buster but they were saying bar back or
I'm bartender a bar back is a busser but
for the bar like they just they fill the
ice and move the cups yeah he need not
be a bus or maybe like um assistant
manager right I know if Peter doesn't
want to get involved in drama like take
a seat
I can't lose he uninvited James from
iceberg it was so funny could you
imagine James like they couldn't have
had another blow-up so immediately
everyone needs to talk about the first
book first honestly though when Arianna
was walking in to Petersburg they really
got me thinking because she looked like
she was wearing really chill clothing
it's like it must be so nice to like be
paid to hang out and drink with your
friends and have those plans be set up
for you it's like they organized like
the because they always need a private
room feel like screaming in the middle
of the bar with their camera right so
it's like oil inks are paid for your
plans are made for you you just have to
show up I'm like that's nice thing
you're getting paid to like hang out
with your friends in a comfortable spot
yeah but they don't have to like air a
lot of your dirty like that's a plus
side for sure and then he like go behind
the bar and metal their own drinks and
like make their own shots which is just
really cute yeah let's talk about the
rock I love it all okay cuz I saw you
were waiting in the master post that
some not some unkind words about her
what what did I say that she's annoying
or stupid what um I thought she handled
herself really well and I and I I said
the same thing last week and you have to
think about it this way like until she
knows confirmed that James cheated on
her and yes everyone says but really
where's the hard evidence like everyone
Stassi was like isn't it known that
James cheats on her all the time like
but yet they bring a girl in and her
story has holes in it you know like give
me some if it's so prevalent give me
some hard evidence that you can
a picture from that girl right that
picture like it wasn't like she could
have been it could have been a party
where they were all like asleep and like
you know people crash and then she just
like went over there to know like I have
text messages and yeah
nude photo anything so she has and like
she's with James she loves him so like
obviously she's gonna have his back
until she really can't anymore and so
she's in a terrible position yeah having
to defend this person who not only might
be doing terrible things to her but it's
even if he's not still doing terrible
things to other people right and like
she wouldn't address that part you know
what I mean like she would it be she's
happier to talk about like the faith and
I'm what's her name I hope the hope
we're hope um
she's happier to talk about like the
cheating rumors like she didn't even
address the fact that he called Katie
that like which is like the worst she
didn't know right no but then when she
did she was like oh no but then when she
hears it and people tell her these
things like I guess she really is never
around for it yeah and it's all like
news to her and so it's like she has to
condemn it but she's never seen it cuz
he treats her nicely except for when he
doesn't that was like really sad yeah
but it's like oh and Stassi was saying
she's like can relate to her Britney can
too like they've all been in this
position so I really right now don't
take umbrage with her because I one
don't think she's got enough hard
evidence to totally like they should be
nicer to her actually
Christine this is so scary yeah and she
really is Sweeting just like wants to
get along like she's never done anything
no but she really wants to say on the
show is what she wants yes the show was
her whole life and James is her ticket
on to the show and she hasn't made
enough of an impact on her own to like
stay on if they broke up of course she
needs to become friends with these girls
and Britney might be just might be the
ticket that you know Britney was I
really was so on board with Britney
reaching out to her because that's
exactly what she needs and if she ever
is gonna leave James she's gonna need a
group of girls to have her back the beer
Qi is so funny oh my god I would love to
try it
no like good for the kids and matter of
her pearls like really like strike like
they try everything like they wanted to
write a cocktail book Katie has a blog -
Stassi has a podcast like t-shirt
company like they oh they try everything
and one of them is gonna make a big ones
Tom they got Tom Tom from that so good
for them here for it yeah they're very
much aware that like this is a wonderful
opportunity that they should seize why
was in la la' at the girls dinner I
don't know why was in LA why in the
whole episode it's so an unfair I know
cuz like she's the only person
want to say and better you see that in
real life she had her engagement party
yes and it's not filmed cuz they're not
filming right now I love her so much I
love her so much I just want to watch a
show where like she needs a definition
of like a phoenix rising from the ashes
like they they wanted anyone but her on
the show like they did everything they
could talk make her scared sad mean no
so it's like now that and now they eat
her [ __ ] you never know like where
Raquel could be in the year or two years
so true you know yeah so crazy
what was the fourth thing you want to
show after now oh okay oh my god I
actually watch SNL because I wanted to
see Pete Davidson I wanted to see Miley
and I watched on demand and you couldn't
skip and it was really Mike I really
only watched it to watch Miley and let's
just talk about her jacket right I was
freaking out I was freaking out not that
nothing I saw the nipple was gonna slip
honestly because I'm sure NBC was like
had [ __ ] Berg masking tape like so I
didn't think something was gonna come
out but it was an interesting style
choice you know I didn't like it and I
didn't think it was stylish no I liked
the outfit I didn't like how much of her
bare chest she showed because it would
have been like that's really something
for like a bigger breasted woman there
was just like so much skin with like
like nothing you know no I yes it just a
little I would have zipped it or like
alito like something top yeah we're like
a band just cuz it was it was it was
very distracting it really wasn't she
sounded good and you know what when I
was watching her perform I was thinking
about what I said about her in the
podcasts the other day I take back like
I think her music is fake and she's like
not a real singer she sounded so good
and that song is pretty good that sounds
pretty good she's an amazing singer and
I love Mark Ronson I love Mark Ronson
the war's over cover was so so good and
did you know that the guitarist was John
Lennon's son yeah and he looks just like
literally like a walking combination of
John Lennon and Yoko and I loved that
look did it feel to you like she was
reading the lyrics off of something
she was Margo I noticed it and then
Margo said did you notice and I said yes
and now you said it too and I oh it was
like it was it's fine because it's like
it's a song she's singing it's a very
well known song she's singing it in
front of his son she didn't wanna be
disrespectful I just wish they had put
it at an eye level teleprompter because
she kept looking down visibly and that
was like that was rude yeah I wonder why
they distracted her after she had like
Britain it and I posted it like taped it
on the stage
yeah with my notes interesting it was
weird the rest of the episode Pete
Davidson came on just to introduce my
Cyrus which by the way is what the host
usually does so they put him there I
think just let everyone know like he's
alive here it is okay yeah Matt Damon
was funny I never thought if he was like
a funny guy I like honestly I don't
really understand like 80% of the
political jokes and the first wonderful
life thing I literally didn't understand
was watching I'm like I don't understand
any of this I came in midway through so
I didn't even I tried it and I don't
really watch SNL because so much of it
is political and they that's annoying
and be I don't get it like I don't get
it like if someone's doing an impression
of like a senator you don't even know if
it's gonna break except I didn't know
that eighty Bryant was being Sarah
Huckabee and like she looked just like
he does a great job it was so funny but
I guess because this was like a holiday
episode it was all Christmas themed and
so like it was really very few politics
and I really enjoyed it
like just it was straight comedy and
some of it was stupid like that one
where they were the back of the
Christmas tree that was like it was so
poorly done that Kenan Thompson's legs
when I say yeah it was so stupid
maybe that was how it's supposed to be
was just like a made torso it was bad
like that was bad comedy bad writing bad
GCI I mean since you're all the show is
really bad comedy and what's so scary
and crazy is like these are the best
comic minds and this is the best like
that Weezer fight oh that was so stupid
but I found myself giggling and a couple
things like it was funnier than I then I
remembered because I hadn't watched it
and so long and like credit where credit
is due like some things were funny and I
was like you're going like the concepts
for some of those sketches are so stupid
but like for the most part I was
giggling and I just want to talk about
Weekend Update because we're obsessed
with Colin Jost in the fact that he
works one day a week but it was bad
beginner things like that as per usual
but there was a segment at the end where
like for the holidays the gifts they're
giving each other is they wrote jokes
for each other so they had put in
pre-written jokes in the teleprompter
Michael wrote for callin and callin
wrote for Michael Collins for Michael
we're so not funny like I was literally
painful like I'm like a fake comedian
and I swear I could have done a better
job the ones Michael were for Colin
we're so funny the last one was so funny
so but like the Rosa Parks life right
like oh my god and saying bye I'm
starting it by saying Michael actually
didn't write this one I wrote right that
was funny and like we saw Colin and
Michael
was both of them both of them yeah and
they were we saw them perform like a 20
minute set at a charity event once and
they were really funny and I really I
changed my whole thing and ah yes but
and I firmly believe that Michael che is
funny like I I think he's funny I think
he's a great writer I think he writes a
lot of the biscuits for us tonight like
he is a talent and that tubeset
two-minute segment was a testament to
that it was so funny agreed also another
decent sketch but like still failed to
land the plane as Sara Foster would say
the Oscar hosts hysterical I'm sorry
so funny I thought that was hilarious
but things like they everyone did their
best impression bruh and went home right
so it was like who do we land on no who
do we land on like we're not saying
anything I just feel like there's so
much of that going like bubbling in this
climate right and they don't say
anything
no they just like barley make a joke no
like they just like I remember when all
that stuff with Harvey Weinstein
happened and all this meat and like they
literally would not address Harvey
Weinstein and then they did this sketch
of like a fake Tribeca Film Festival
forum where they literally had Kate
McKinnon being like an old I'm sorry I
would watch an hour and a half of just
Kate McKenna no and like they know that
and so they literally threw her at the
problem they're like Harvey Weinstein me
too was happening we have we won't
address it for whatever reason Kate
McKinnon do your thing like they just
she took the show on her back and she
was like an 80 year old old actress on
to Tribeca Film Festival panel talking
about what used to happen to her in the
UC and it was so like it was so funny
but like I didn't forget that they still
weren't saying adjusting or like really
know the hypocrisy it's just so real
it's crazy
no but Kate McKinnon really Kate
McKinnon and Ken and Kenan Thompson put
the shell on their back like I really
know how Kenan Thompson is so funny and
he can never leave the show I hope he
makes 7 million dollars a year like he
is whatever he's getting it's not enough
he is so funny and him and kate mckinnon
really put the show on their back and
any sketch they're in is automatically
funny just cuz they do such good
impersonation but like the dog the daddy
show was so stupid like oh my god so
stupid and it had such potential right
like when it opened like that was
already laughing like funny Westminster
Dog Show for daddies and like say daddy
again and I'm gonna [ __ ] throw a
party we were going on a two-hour show
I'm sorry okay okay so that was the
morning too
most we are at 99.5 K on Instagram and
like I'm a hell-bent I can actually show
you guys I'm [ __ ] sweating through my
sweater please I forgot that the foster
sisters were here please follow us
you're still here how many people are
watching right now 1500 Oh Jim okay
that's tacky Oh problems you know she's
working hard too we love you guys
tomorrow is our last show of the season
we are done for the year tomorrow which
starts every starting season to engage
are we gonna call it season to me [ __ ]
yeah tomorrow's a serious season finale
of the morning toast we're gonna do some
like fun wrap-up stuff we'll figure it
out but it's been a wild ride and we'll
make it a more emotional speech tomorrow
but thanks for sticking around you guys
we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you